[Music]
Charlotte I would like to endorse you to
be the next president of the United
States oh my god you've been a great
Secretary of State which state again all
of them Secretary of State looking at us
I kind of know her it's like kind of
known a mermaid do you tell people that
replies remember who I am
secretary field I'd like to speak with
you with me I can't shake this feeling
that we know each other we do we do
picture me I guess maybe like 20 years
younger but like this Barsky
yeah what are you doing these days I'm a
journalist you're a great writer but
sometimes you're a little too much I'm
the perfect right portion it's really
nice to see you again okay you policemen
just call me a cracker what is the
relationship exactly it's to babysit for
them you babysat for him
Wow time has not been kind I need some
writers to punch up my speeches Fred's
writing is really good and he knows me
oh I feel so scared I know what right
better for you
I should kind of get to know you better
and if you have a minute I actually have
seven seven minutes in heaven what is
there pretty ring as a kid The Velveteen
Rabbit fair John must have been loved by
rocks a most embarrassing moment
what's your favorite sexual position
normal facing normal question is that
what's your favorite sexual position do
be gross friend do a date I mean who
wants to follow me around the world and
hope I have five minutes to be
affectionate yeah we actually did almost
die we need to move you Thank You agent
M it's pretty woman but she's Richard
Gere and you're Julia Roberts honestly
this is a bit of the best few weeks of
my entire life thousand constituents how
they would feel if Kate Middleton say
we're going with us we're to start
dating Danny DeVito pretty negative
reaction
the last time you got I was on a swing
doctors
[Music]
we had a situation what's happened
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]